thank you very much a huge honor to
speak here and hopefully a real pleasure
to be able to give a talk with
more technical and i usually get invited
see you ought to give um there's no
there are not two screens here where I
can see myself which is going to be very
distracting I introduced myself to some
people at lunch and I'm probably just
going to repeat myself but my group
which we found in about two thousand six
has been very successful working across
a wide range of media and wide range of
canvases and situations and part of that
is being exceptional luck good fortune
and part of it has been our ability to
navigate several different worlds
without compromising our cells as
artists we are artists first we are
passionate about that that's what we do
when we get up in the morning and it's
how we pay our mortgages but other than
luck this is my other secret ingredient
that I spend about a third of my time in
the white heat of making art so sitting
in front of computer programs that I've
written or sitting in theatres and
making decisions about how big this
should be what color should be how fast
it should move i spend about a third of
my time doing research into how i might
want to make our computer graphics
rendering systems computer vision mainly
culling stuff from academia and
implementing it myself or hacking it
together and then i spent the last third
of my time working on tools to help me
do those two things and the second half
of what i'm going to be talking about
today will be specifically on the tools
that I've constructed in order to make
my art in this way the secret forum the
secret for maybe paying attention during
this talk or getting something from it
is this identity up here which holds
nowhere except for the duration of my
top because
one hypothesis that I've had for a few
years now is that there is at this time
in this contemporary moment and
incredibly important convergence between
art science and engineering practice so
the values remain completely different
we we care about different things and we
evaluate ourselves in very different
ways and our aesthetics our tendencies
are very different but the way that art
is working in the way that science is
working in some conditions and where the
engineering is working is reaching a
point of contact so as a digital artist
that works with a variety of inputs I
spend much of my life hacking my way
into large data sets and it might be
data sets that I've commissioned like a
film or they might be something I'm
working on a theater with a dance
company I have motion capture of some
choreography or have done something
weird with cameras and but I'll go to
that and I'll say well somewhere in this
data there is something which will catch
my eye and I have to dig it out I have
to find the sort of potential which is
latent in this until it satisfies my eye
my heart and my feeling is that science
and engineering converging to a point
where the software stacks are very tall
the algorithms are often not owned by
the researcher the data sets are large
and often not commissioned specifically
for a particular experiment and
researchers have to dig their way into
these data sets in order to find
something which catches their eye and
satisfies that as researchers so you can
for the purposes of talk whenever I talk
about art try to hear science or
engineer my story though begins sort of
halfway through my PhD I'd like to like
to tell you a story of a man who writes
computer programs to make art sitting in
a theater with an American choreographer
called Trisha Brown who's very famous
and incredibly
talented choreographer and she has a
dance company and we're working on a
piece together called how long does the
subject linger on the edge of the volume
it's great title and it's a real-time
motion capture piece we have a motion
capture of studio on stage back in 2003
this is rocket science and in 2013 I had
my lunch in a library that had a motion
capture studio but 2003 it was it was
very hard to do and we had it was so
hard that we had three years to make
this piece and residency after residency
I was did by Arizona State University
and I'm sitting in a theater and I know
her work very well and I love her work
and I'm trying to keep up with his
choreographer and she's working in a
very algorithmic way she gives problems
to her dancers and they solved those
problems and then she finds the bits of
their solutions but she likes and she
calls those moments into evening line
dance piece I'm sitting there typing
away and I realized that I cannot keep
up you can't say to her come back
tomorrow when I fixed my bug and nor do
I want to prepare all my stuff ahead of
time back in the comfort of MIT and then
kind of take my bag of tricks out and
just shake it in front of her I want to
actually collaborate in the moment I
want to be able to keep up so we made
ultimately a piece looked a bit like
this the live visuals were projected on
a transparent screamed in front of the
dancers real-time motion capture set up
so my code knew where the dancers were
on when it worked incredibly precisely
and I tried to develop and I still try
to develop today a coding methodology a
practice that combines all the things I
saw in her work on that tries to sort of
be as good at what I do is she was what
she does and the key ingredients are
these that there's there's something
both improv Satori and rehearsal about
what she did she could improvise on the
spot and produce problems that revealed
results that she was not expecting
but she could then practice those things
and fix them and then slowly construct
them into finished piece so there was an
openness to the possibilities of the
unforeseen but there was a discipline
and control about what she could then do
with the things that she found and then
finally that she had a kind of
omnivorous on a practice that could
absorb like many other modern
choreographers absorb all kinds of
fields and she would be influenced by
linguistics by computer science by
visual art by drawing one of the key
things I did in order to survive that
encounter is I developed some some
software agents that would hang out with
her in the in the studio and these were
agents which were rehearsal so this is a
triangle creatures the creature it
starts off as a triangle and plays a
game where it tries to go from stage
left stage right on in about three and
five minutes so as the choreography
solidified this agent got better and
better at working out when to connect to
the dancers in order to get a push in
the right direction and when to
disconnect from the dancers in order not
to be dragged back to where it started
and these are sped up iterations of that
learning process the dots at the bottom
are the dancers one of the joys of
working on a transparent scrim is you
can share the space with the dancers
here and you have this entire campus
about to work so that was kind of the
first glimpse I had of a couple of
things one that learning algorithms were
very useful for putting me in the right
position with respect to my complicated
computer programs that by assembling a
agent which could learn or be poked and
prodded in the right ways I could do
that off-site and then I could turn up
into the theater and I would have a
relationship with this with this agent
that was useful to me as an artist and
that satisfied the sort of demands and
challenges and opportunities of
text i was in after I graduated I it was
Mozart's birthday he was 250 and AH we
were commissioned to make a piece for to
celebrate monster's birthday by the
mostly Mozart festival in Lincoln Center
and we came up with a very elaborate
cluster of computers that would
decompose not motion capture of dance
company or anything else but the last 45
seconds of Mozart's last Symphony which
is almost secretly five-part invertible
counterpoint so at the end of this
wonderful symphony that sounds like
Mozart he reveals that all of the
thematic material you've heard thus far
fits together as perfect jigsaw puzzle
and he states the few wants and then
that's it he's done he's done with
symphony so he's almost done with his
life and so we we built this is where it
was installed on the front of Avery
Fisher Hall we asked the conductor Louie
long gray to help us kind of decompose
the end of this he went at peace music
with some magic markers we then trained
the computer to do the same thing so to
recognize the themes as they were being
stated both in the ending and in the
entire movement and then we build a
piece that would slowly put the jigsaw
puzzle back together again
of which I have some video documentation
here so there were on 10 computers with
10 screens and 10 speakers each computer
had an instrument in the orchestra and
we unfolded we unfolded the orchestra in
the front of the building I'm the first
five or six seconds were literally
random notes and then slowly automatic
set up a tonal center emerges and then
the thematic material emerges and then
the replacement gets put into the right
position with respect to the screens
which are nearby and then eventually you
have a CD quality recording of the
entire motion after about anywhere
between 25 and 35 minutes and then the
computer performs the piece the 45
seconds of music and throws it all the
way and starts again and it was
installed continuously for about six
weeks in the summer heat of New York
so one of the rules of the piece is that
we we took all of the one performer from
each musical instrument into a recording
studio and filmed them while building up
this multitrack recording of the piece
so as the p6 closer and closer to Mozart
are diagrammatic visual style which is
illustrating the compositional processes
which are going on moves more and more
towards having motion from the
underlying performance so these
diagrammatic things get interrupted by
skeletons of performers this is around
the second phase where the thematic
material is beginning to be discovered
so this whole thing is kind of a
35-minute dramatization of directed
search
that was a violin was playing that
darker
that's what I look like
Oh
that's my favorite bit there where they
all kind of relax lay out so there were
two pieces there on one that took place
in a theater with a wonderful dance
company I one that took place in kind of
conversation with Mozart over the ages
and the one of the theater led me
towards these learning algorithms and
agents as a formal device for making art
this one led me towards a separate set
of concerns where you can't make a 35
minute long piece with a compile cycle
because if something bad happens 34
minutes in you can't you just can't
start again from scratch you just go and
say so the tools I needed to build their
looked a lot like what the cool cats
today are calling live coding I needed
something that would let me hack into a
live system that was running to inspect
it to modify it to tweak it and the
infrastructure behind that to keep track
of what the hell I was doing in order to
make pieces that had that kind of length
and even today that piece was a few
years old there's a tremendous number of
pieces of digital art which are about
three minutes long there's a kind of a
scale there because the tools that are
being used to construct them I have a
compile cycle you have to tear it down
start it up every damn time you change
now the ways around that of course even
in compiled languages and compiled
platform you start to build bits of user
interface for yourself and the tools
I've constructed help you do that but
try to provide a smoother try to get rid
of some of the impedance mishmash that
you have before you get to that one so
the next piece I want to talk about is a
piece called into the forest which marks
are sort of return to motion and one of
the things about our relationship to
dance is that we've had the great
fortune to work with the best
choreographers
world but once we've worked with them
once we kind of get burnt out on dance
so we thought to ourselves what can we
do which is kind of opposite to dance
and the opposite to dance for us is is
children's motion so we made a game that
drew upon a library of motion capture
data that we constructed of children
playing hide-and-seek it turns out it's
very hard at least back then too motion
capture children so we found a couple of
mimes on craigslist to pretend to be
children and they were very good at it
so we had this large very large database
of of pretend children mocap that we cut
up into pieces and then the game was
really two components to the game one is
can we build some agents which
automatically piece that motion capture
back together again in order to create
an endless game of hide-and-seek in a
forest that was constantly shifting and
could we make that beautiful and we've
made this piece a couple of times in the
last version of it was a stereoscopic
interactive projection that museum with
moving image in New York which I think
was the first connect based interactive
art work in a major museum we threw out
our complicated stereoscopic camera rig
about two weeks before the opening and
replaced it Microsoft Kinect so the
ultimate peace ultimately look like this
I might look a bit better if we had a
little bit less light in here but I
don't know if that would compromise the
video of this no one's really listening
to me all right imagine this was fifty
percent better also imagine this was in
stereo which is obviously something I
can't do here so this is the sort of
hallucinogenic memory and fantasy of
childhood and a force that changes
whenever the cameras back is turned so
trees that used to be there or will
disappear and be replaced with rocks and
other topology and hiding in here are a
set of
figures that are playing hide and seek
forever
so to build that piece we made our own
game engine in a sense and we did a very
good job of it we built all of the
things that were the standard trapping
of high-end computer games at the time
we had high dynamic range lighting we
had careful soft shadows we had fake
film grain what was different about this
is we took all of those well implemented
components and we glued them together in
non physically correct ways so we would
have times when lights would cash not
shadows but zones of clarity the film
grain would get swept up by the motion
that was underneath it on the color
palette was compressed in a herd of the
oddball way and unwrapped in
non-traditional ways and by producing
something which was both physically
inspired but not the physics of our real
world we ended up with a form that was
medium like so because it had its own
physical integrity it had some pushback
it was a complex system that wouldn't
necessarily do what it was told it was
something that you had to dig your way
into and the tool support that we needed
for that was really kind of mining our
mining data about our own explorations
of this complicated parameter space so
that we could locate islands that we
were interested in and that we could
audition interpolations between those
sets of parameters and perturb those in
directions that we found most favorable
and so the game of hide-and-seek was
played by the children and sometimes by
the person standing in front of the
kinect but also in a rendering parameter
space it gave it a sort of wide variety
of visual styles when it was installed
the next to last piece that I want to
talk about is one that we opened a
couple of weeks ago which is I want to
talk about because it's actually in some
senses a return to the concerns that I
had for the piece I did Trisha Brown
this is a piece one of several that
we've done with a British
before called Wayne McGregor and we've
worked on four pieces with him now this
was a different kind of commission we I
wanted to give him this was a love
letter for me to him and I gave him an
11th dancer he has 10 dancers in his
company and I gave him a piece that
would sit in the corner of his studio as
he made a dance piece and the piece that
he was making which premiered also a
couple of weeks ago I was B's called
Atomos and there was a secret text to it
an iconic 80s science fiction film that
I'm not allowed to name was given to all
of the collaborators as they're sort of
point of departure was given to the
composer's and the dancers and and me
earlier on we've done a piece called the
choreographic language agent which was a
of whether or not we could build him a
tool that would get him programming so
what is a programming environment for a
choreographer well it turns out and you
either know this because you're in the
field already done because you're not on
there's a huge line a huge current
through modern dance which involves the
use of geometric abstraction in order to
produce movement and to keep dancers off
balance you ask them to imagine lines in
space and then rotate their bodies
around or problems that involve
geometries of their own bodies so we
built them a kind of abstract geometric
computer you could try out operations on
stick figures and other connections of
dots a programming environment that
would kind of be a midpoint between
computational concerns i had and
concerns ehat but for this 11 dancer we
gave them a much simpler interface here
you could select a clip it's getting
darker all the time lyrics right you can
select a clip from this film which I
want a name and we automatically
decomposed it into twelve hundred and
forty five shots
um which turns out that's how many
scenes there are no movie and you could
select one of them and one part of the
motion of it and tell this piece
becoming to respond to that and it was
an autonomous artwork that would
iteratively much slower than this as
it's being sped up start from a point
grow its body change its musculature and
when its muscles fired and keep going
heading towards trying to capture as
much of the motion that it found in that
scene there's a big lump of computer
vision that happened offline and then
again a directed heuristic search about
whether or not this creature could
capture all of the person walking around
or someone crashing through a
plate-glass window that was in the scene
that being selected and other than
selecting the video material that went
into it this creature hung out both in
his studio and it was installed in a
museum in london what you can't see here
is that it was in stereo and because it
was installed on a kind of 70-inch
plasma display that was portrait it had
a kind of physical presence that was
completely appropriate to the contact it
was dancer sized and had a articulation
and a volume to it that was very much
human scale and I think it's probably
the most interesting motion that I've
ever ever synthetically created insofar
as it makes me and makes the dancers
actually want to move it has a real
kinesthetic response the last piece I
want to talk about that true the last
piece I want to talk about is this one
this is pissa that we also opened about
three weeks ago we've been very busy
mississippi's called all day and it was
a celebration really of brooklyn
received a commission from the Barclays
Center which is a new stadium
in Brooklyn and they wanted three things
or we wanted to give them three things
they have a large LED wall on the front
of the building which is a very strange
shape and we gave him a 5-channel short
film as well and a stereoscopic version
that is it for good measure and we took
as input to this about 50,000
photographs of Brooklyn and this is one
of the pieces that we've made using
point cloud reconstruction from
unstructured or semi structured select
sets of photographs and the data set
that we had to dig into was this
tremendous and extremely undisciplined
set of photographs the people who own
the Barkley Stadium it turns out own the
piece ended up looking like this own
lots of properties around Brooklyn so we
could get roof access to like half the
city so our fifty thousand photographs
were mainly taken from these incredible
vantage points that no one else can get
to and the final piece looks a bit like
this
but in stereo
got out of there so in addition to that
we delivered this 5 channel piece which
was built out of a sort of procedural
rear ndering of that material that
ultimately yielded about two hours of
material on this is installed
permanently on the eight on the inside
because once we've constructed this
system where you can then make
procedural deformations of each scene in
order to provide a kind of string of
screens and it becomes a game you
actually have to slow the video down
here it becomes a game of comparing
contrasting adjacent monitors but the
last thing was this beautiful canvas
that they gave us on the outside there's
a thing that I call the oculus which is
it I got it curved LED wall that is a it
goes from a ribbon to fat pocket and
back up again in a circle so we recast
our material one more time in order to
fit on this strangely shaped incredibly
bright LED wall and for a while like
this we went right back to our time in
the theater in a sense we had incredibly
little rehearsal time McDonald's and
Nike feel that they own this thing and
to get time on the device time to
iterate on the devices it was incredibly
hard because you know they have
advertising commitments so the ability
to move fast and on the spot was what
made this made the difference between
making art and just making a splash I
think so the other thing that I want to
talk about or at least kind of point
atoms day as a thing called field which
gave gives the other meaning to the
title of this piece it's not just me
going out into the world and trying to
take advantage of the of the
opportunities I find their field is a
project that I started as a PhD student
and have kept with me as central to my
practice as a programming artist since
then and
on it tries to reimagine what
programming could be and and tries to be
a minimal environment one that embodies
just enough graphical user interface
design just enough ego and preference
and statement by me just enough drawing
capability because I think it turns out
the ability to draw and notate with very
little cost becomes incredibly important
in these kinds of programming
environments and just enough of a
relationship to various ecosystems of
various clients it is a java-based ID
for what the cool cats are calling live
coding these days it's written in Java
it's primarily for writing Python
although we've been using other JVM
languages recently closure in particular
and it also comes with a high
performance super contemporary open GL
graphics system which is beginning to be
used at various universities for doing
big data visualization and all itself on
the other way of stating it is a
programming language sure for when you
don't know what you're doing it's a
branding language for the panic attack
in the theater but it cuz it's a
programming language to let you make
mistakes over and over again as you
fumble towards digging that thing mining
that potential out of the work that
you're doing so here's a screenshot sort
it has a text editor it has a canvas it
has various rendering windows of various
kinds and the text editor is I think
maybe the one of the coolest things
about it it has a couple of things going
on which you can see from the screenshot
one is that it has very nice support for
auto completion and it does a very good
job of trying to glean as much
information as it can out of source
files and Java Docs and other ways of
introspecting that ends up being
incredibly important when you're
stitching together other people's code
the ability to explore
very deeply the surface of a library
that what you've just downloaded from
Google is an important difference
between success and failure the other
thing which is going on here is that you
can embed graphical user elements you
can see the text editor directly one of
the reasons that people in the digital
art community don't write code and use
other tools is because changing a number
and over over over again textually feels
boring and time-consuming so the trick
is to have a graphical user interface
elements that compile or just secretly
masquerade as text um and you can embed
them and pretend that they're text and
you can copy and paste them and move
them around and there's a level of field
which is completely oblivious to the
fact that the 0.3 05 you have written is
secretly a slider sliders are an obvious
example but graphs are huge pain to
specify and imagine and then Tay Ninh
your head and if you can do it then just
come back tomorrow and find that you
have lost the memory of what that graph
looks like but once you've opened the
box you have all kinds of more exotic
gooey things you can stick in your text
editor this is a uh this is a lazy box
that will not evaluate to its number 20
but evaluate to something which will go
and find the contents of that box later
so you can defer evaluation of parts of
your code so even it once this this text
box has been evaluated and function is
perhaps being called from somewhere else
I can edit that 20 and it will update
automatically so i can even display
whether or not that function has been
called whether that value has been
revealed to the outside world and then I
can start doing things like this so this
is a piece of Python which embeds
another programming language in it in
this case closure
and that just evaluates to that blow
there are people who are comfortable
with pison will see the trick that's
going on I hand that to a different
runtime different environment for
compilation and execution so I can
change my mind about what primate
language I'm coding it as I go I can do
things like that i can ask like a moment
of apple script halfway through a for
loop you just grimace another more
useful example than calling a speech
synthesizer is calling bash and there
are other things in the text editor
which i think are interesting and
relevant these areas appear in a margin
that do two things they remind you of
what blocks you were executed they
appear automatically and give you a
quick way of executing them again and
there's a tendency now I think in some
of the really young live coding
environments that parsing and execution
is is always good and should just be
happening ambient Lee and what they
generally lack are ways to quickly
specify and maintainable ways this the
part that you want to re-execute over
and over again and that's a kind of a
vital ingredient the code that is in the
text editor lives in boxes which are
drawn in the canvas the other window
there's an object model of sorts their
boxes can refer to themselves and can
find other boxes there's enough tools
that you can build you want to hierarchy
in a data flow between them and which
you can programmatically inspect and
programatically modify its self
extensible in a way that will appeal to
Emacs users you can write code which
extends the environment I spent two
weeks forcing myself to write
exclusively closure in field just to get
myself in the swing of learning
programming languages and so my first
task was to extend field to do tab and
enter properly for a lisp like language
which I was able to do in a lisp light
language
inside the environment itself but
there's no sense the field is the one
final solution to any particular problem
and I don't actually have a horse in the
race of winning the environment Wars
this is a piece of code which is
executed somewhere else it's executed
inside a software product called max/msp
which is a hugely popular environment
for sound processing and music that code
is parceled up and sent to this box here
and it is parcel up and send in such a
way that you can still code iteratively
that that code is executed autonomously
inside max ms peace process and that
auto completion still works and i found
that you can also do the same trick with
web browsers so I sending JavaScript for
execution in web browsers I found that
there their whole set of products that
you can sort of back door almost most of
the Autodesk products except Python
which is enough for you to install
something that acts as a gateway for
field most of the Adobe products of a
secret JavaScript back door sometimes
you have to go through apple script is a
little weird most of the apple products
of course have apple script and then the
maximum SP sort of music family will
have hiding away in the corner of at a
java runtime which is enough enough of a
gap for you to drive a cart through and
then there's a drawing a notation system
that lets you illustrate things which
are happening on this campus so there's
code living in these boxes the code that
to draw these elements on here this
little slider here is a box which
executes the things that it hits so now
we have a timeline matter for let's just
sort of merged that can get out of hand
this is a score for a tiny little bit of
a piece that we did where I needed the
ability to align things to music so a
little bit musical analysis and suddenly
I have what do I have I've got basically
ninety percent of adobe after effects I
have my timeline matter for I have code
that pulls and JPEGs from
texture maps them I'm basically done I
have a multi-layer video editing suite
for very little cost and then finally
there's just enough of a relationship to
several huge ecosystems so Java there's
tremendous amount of existing code
written in Java that you spend some
fraction or time googling for existing
code and incorporating it onto your
classpath there's an equally large
amount of code that's written in Python
and their support there for that style
of practicing grab something in test it
explore its properties an algorithm see
if it works use it or discard it
hopefully my goal is not for everybody
to use field my goal is to try it to
unglue on the notion of a software
product especially for creative worlds
so it occurs to me as I look at my hard
drive I have all of these timelines Maya
logic after facts quicktime max/msp i
think has two timelines hiding in it on
there all implement re implementations
of the same conceptual structure and
this is offensive in two ways one is
that it's a tremendous amount of wasted
effort but really the most offensive
thing is that they don't talk to each
other at all and if we radically rican
sieved how we distribute and think of
software there would be a set of
competing timeline components that would
be able to talk quicktime and music and
various other things and we would
destabilize on unglue what we think of a
monolithic software product and
fragmented out and we would be in a much
happier and frankly more futuristic spot
whether a relationship to getting
computers to do interesting things this
is the same diagram with data flow
concept now these two things are as old
as the hills these are ideas from the
60s and 70s and yet they are apparently
still vibrant and interesting because
they're all over my hard drive
what can we do to to stop me being able
to make this diagram in the future can
we end this I don't know shield is on
github I think we used to be beta and
now I'm feeling kind of alpha sh about
it it works great on Linux it probably
still works great on ms 10 and i would i
would love to continue the conversation
either in person or around this
development in the future and the
shameless plug for our piece that I'm
doing with my partners and they are kept
in ski and December 7th and 8th in bing
Hall you're all invited you'll see a
wonderful concert thank you very much as
a third seven finalized video is there
like a filter process that goes there or
that's being generated live like just as
you're capturing it before the finalized
video well yes all right so is there a
number of I guess final video products
are from the motion capture from the
cityscape like shots are you taking in
raw film and then um so that so let's
take all day which was one of our point
cloud pieces um you go out into the
world you shoot a whole bunch of
photographs you try to be disciplined
about it that something catches your eye
taking off course um you come back
you've got you know terabyte of stuff um
prominent was blind petitioners edge to
various things and then run low on
computational tasks on them in kind of
modern you can't have an operations
problem there um results come trickling
in as point cloud successfully computer
or fail to converge so you have to
explore those results well perhaps
running Lord
simultaneously you're trying to work out
how you're going to draw this point clap
so you have a real time graphic system
that can take in these results that you
can poke with various ways you have
extra analytical tasks which use the
photography and reproject them back out
onto the point clouds you're developing
those at the same time right and they're
all coming together in a very real time
way because ultimately what you're
looking for is a moment where all the
people involved in the project me and my
partners are sitting in beautiful
theater somewhere or our lousy studio
space or something looking at the piece
hopefully at scale you know the scale
it's going to be made in making
decisions about well this should be
thicker this should be faster they
should move this way that way so even
though you ultimately ship a finished
piece on the speaks it's going to be
shown at moma in a few weeks it's a
cinema you send a digital cinema package
on a hard drive it it's a directory full
of JPEG 2000 even though it's completely
canned you've made it through this
real-time moment it allows collaboration
to occur because you can all point out
and say i think that sucks i mean no
more of that that's great more of this
and you've got tools support in the case
of field to let you draw those things
you've got a good graphic system and
you've got a way to make decisions
quickly about what it is you like did
that answer yes alright
times at beginning about basically
poking prodding a large amounts of data
define interesting paths really I'm
wondering what we can if you were
support such that more people feel
comfortable doing that I think that it's
it's a competency that's hard to learn I
completely agree with you on until about
two weeks ago so two weeks ago I had a
very odd week when I was I went back to
your place called impact which is a huge
performing arts center in upstate New
York which I've often had the wonderful
experience of making art in but I went
back not to make art this time I went
back to explore topics in data
visualization and we had we've gone some
data real data from real scientists
they've given us some data kind of blind
they hadn't really told us anything
about it and I was trying to suppress
any kind of engineering knowledge I had
over what the data might be and I was
going to try and find something
interesting in it and I think we've been
played the scientist to try to play a
trick on us they've given us some data
that they thought had nothing in it and
I don't think you were very mean but
there might have been a sense that while
these artists are going to tie
themselves knots trying to find meaning
out of what should be basically white
noise um the first thing we did we had a
data set that had about nine ten million
points in it the points had about three
or four numbers associated them but it's
kind of a 9 10 million point data set
the first thing we do is just stick it
on the screen so 10 million points you
can't plot in Excel 10 million points
you can't do anything on obvious and
dumb and visual in MATLAB but 10 million
points is kind of ok 44 like a decent
open GL graphics I applauded 10 million
points and at point cloud no problem
right it's not state-of-the-art you just
stick it all on the screen and you start
tweaking on the graphics card inch in
shade or the coloring and the mapping
the size of it points and various stupid
things about them immediately all kinds
of things reveal themselves
and the scientists in question had never
thought to visualize this data they
hadn't had any tools to read in the
files that they could barely write out
from their simulations they never
thought to just stick it on the screen
and there was no tool that would let
them just kind of quickly put it out
there as soon as we put on their
incredible vast amounts of structure we
didn't have to go chasing down with
sophisticated algorithms they were just
there and we ended up finding a gigantic
problem in the random number generator
so their idea of white was obviously
completely wrong because they were not
using a random number generator that was
be using random numbers so there wasn't
anything subtle and hidden about that I
think there's a lot of stuff you can
then do afterwards but I feel like
there's a whole bunch of obvious moves
which aren't being made in traditional
visualization pipelines head well trying
together and then changing techniques
from computer grabs computer vision
constructions or compressing various
parts of color space and so on and
that's it that seems to me like a really
important skill but one that is hard
hard to pick up here cannot go back out
and I'm going to how can you help people
get to that I think that's very
impossible of Duty vision teachers can't
really answer that but i think i'm
reading research papers I and but I'm
also you know i'm also very dependent on
things like opencv so and i think i
would love to be more dependent on my CV
if opencv was better in a better shape
and I'd love if in my optimistic moments
i feel that science as a practice is
moving towards having to publish its
code and once we've gone through a
period messy period of five years of
that people realize that they can't just
publish their code they need publisher
code integrated into a framework which
is shared in their little sub
disciplines and that's something had
happened really early on in computer
vision and it kind of fell apart and
then
kind of speaks bacteria and fell apart
but if we reach that point there are
sort of large frameworks of
interoperable stuff that people are
adding to we're almost at the point with
optical flow algorithms right now it's
very hard to publish an optical flow
algorithm without doing it against
publicly available data sets and then
kind of distributing your code so people
can replicate that if we if that broaden
out to cover larger engineering domains
then what we need we need tools to be
able to rapidly find these things and
test them against your work to see if it
solves the problem you want I don't want
that optical flow outer and I want this
one now this one oh yeah that works so
it's again back to rapid visualization
and this sort of omnivorous bricolage
style 40 and then you talked about
having these systems the end in event
and wondering that's basically the same
thing is the units side philosophy
butterfly to multimedia environments or
each game is different I see this very
related under don't you guys voices when
you get this kind of pitch which I don't
do very much because like I say I don't
really have a horse in this race I'm not
wanting to take over the world their
audience to say well isn't this just
brought Victor stuff and their audiences
to say isn't this just Emacs the Emacs
people are harder audience but there is
something old about this there's
something very very old-school about
some of these ideas and now i think that
the you know sitting in front of a
command line piping stuff fails
incredibly in many user interface ways
and and we have to as a community
acknowledge there's a conceptually
interesting idea here which as it's
revealed and implemented and present is
insufficient for the task so insofar as
you're right you're right there's it
there something good it goes way back
about this idea and perhaps in many
respects represents a path not take the
path
diverse out of the UNIX philosophy or
Pat and then another path which diverse
out of the kind of symbolic slist
machine well but those things about
their old I mean why aren't we there why
are why isn't there a competition I mean
I heard a Apple reveal the new mac three
days ago and someone was like finally we
can edit 4k video in real time as I
benighted getting 4k video in real time
on Macintosh machines for three years
and it's not because I'm some
spectacular Lee gifted coder is you know
I have a fast jpg decompression
algorithm it's multi-threaded I have a
timeline that i can write code in and
i'm done it goes to the graphics card
and i can shade it that's it the only
reason that this is hard is the way that
the software old structure that adobe
and apple I've kind of pulled the
baggage of their legacy towards getting
4k to work and that's offensive I mean
it's really awful you should put up with
it the people in this room should tell
you have the we have the tools and the
abilities to do something better than
that yeah you talk about camera rich
piece of every beautiful and I was
interested in which of your pieces do
you think it's the most beautiful and
how what is well just wondering like in
the sense of how do you measure beauty
could you talk of this convergence of
art science and engineering you want
something we're adding oh that's
beautiful art you're beautiful
engineering or beautiful science from
the seat were just both beautiful art I
don't one of the dangers when you give a
talk like this is you're trying to say
my art is great because my engineering
school and you can you've got three
choices either not give talks like this
which is kind of an education and
responsibility you cannot talk at all
which means the press talk about your
work and you don't or you can kind of
deal with the dangers of people thinking
that I'm saying that wire it's good
because my engineering is good I'm
really not these are autonomous artworks
that go into museums and galleries and
theatres and stages to be judged as such
and I've I'm happy to talk about the
stuff behind the scenes because i think
it's that's useful and you have when you
do a decent Stanford you have a kind of
ethical responsibility to let people
being behind it but the two things are
very very second that it stands and
falls for what it is as its installed so
I want to be very clear about that
you